greetings welcome to connect almost
nobody's denied access to this club and
still it's one of America's most
exclusive ones only here in aptly named
Netherland in the middle of Colorado ten
members legally and openly well get high
I found the heavens for marijuana
enthusiasts in the same country where
other people have to stay behind bars
for decades when caught like this
recreational cannabis has been legal
since the beginning of the year in
Colorado but consumption is not allowed
in public somehow those Cheryl and David
finally managed to get the license to
run a cannabis cafe so far it's a rare
exception but one that Cheryl deems
completely sensible because cannabis is
is non-toxic
it's the smokers of it are friendly
there's no reason why if there's bars
why there wouldn't be places where
people can get together and smoke and
herb so it just it we needed a place
early evening the place starts heating
up
the guests are adequately medicated as
they call it and even the card games are
matched to the occasion Club Med only
exists because Cheryl has a certain way
of doing things that tries to distance
the club completely from the criminal
past of the cannabis scene we followed
all the rules we bent over backwards to
do everything right and not just to
follow the rules but you follow what
people would like to see and what not
they would not like to see and we talked
to the community and we talked to the
seniors and we talked to the church and
the church came to bat for us so we just
involved everyone in the process what
helps when trying to make the case for
weed are its medical effects in 22 US
states cannabis is available on
prescription former trucker Jeff Olson
had chronic pain after a complicated leg
fracture marijuana helped him still he
thinks something else will tip the scale
in favor of the soft drug in the US its
profits taxable and all yes yes I don't
see why not
alcohol is a business drains business
I mean it's America for God's sakes we
got a spark in your business when you
say this could be one I feel it's all
win for everyone dreams of the future
not quite the cannabis business is
already trying to industrialize
marijuana in Colorado and on a whole
other level than here at this
mom-and-pop style Club
I'm heading east through the Rockies in
the mid nineteenth century this was the
scene of the Colorado gold rush now
they're digging for gold again but it's
green and it's center is beyond the
mountains cannabis boomtown Denver in
one of the suburbs a real super market
for marijuana the medicine man the whole
place looks like Fort Knox because
inside it's not only full of green gold
but also lots of cash most banks refused
to give cannabis related companies an
account because of the bad image for the
same reason the customers don't want me
filming them even on an early Thursday
afternoon the place is packed
it doesn't make you cough too much take
really too many hits the sales talk
regarding the 70 marijuana strains that
can be bought here is a completely new
experience for me this is Blue Dream
which is a very very fruity uplifting
hybrid sativa it's gonna be nice
uplifting motivational head high very
cerebral nice for video gaming going out
with your buddies hanging out this is
very activity but behind the counter are
the growing facilities and Elan Nelson
offers me a small tour through the
hallowed halls
the Filipina just picked the camera
everything on sale that medicine man is
grown here in this room the employees
simulate fall with certain temperatures
and light cycles and they're actually
training the plant sugar out in across
using a trellis and some wires and that
way we can end up with several buds all
across the canopy of the plant rather
than just one large bud on top THC as
possible that is the goal THC it has a
lot of medicinal and recreational value
tetrahydrocannabinol or THC is what's
responsible for the effects when
consuming cannabis on these buds it's
even visible as white borders business
is going so well that medicine man is
investing the equivalent of 1.9 million
euros to double production when we were
just a medical marijuana dispensary we
were seeing about a hundred patients a
day and that was that's a successful
business model already and now to being
both medical and recreational we're
seeing about 300 patients and customers
every day now that's why the whole place
is bustling with activity especially in
this room where excess leaves are
trimmed before drying DC as he's called
here might be a little eccentric but
he's by far the fastest there's a unique
vibe to the place certainly also due to
the fact that everybody here has a
different professional background
there's no such thing as a degree in
cannabis trade
well actually I hired on as their
computer guy and I just kind of like
this and I do the computer work too but
yeah if you had asked me last January if
I had pictured this is a career option I
would have had no idea and I called you
crazy amazing how it works out well
maybe and in some US states it would
still be crazy to touch marijuana let
alone get caught with it the Missouri
Department of Corrections has given me
an appointment to interview a prisoner
who more than anyone else is a symbol
for the incredible differences in u.s.
cannabis legislation Jeff mizanskey has
been in prison for about 20 years now
because of marijuana he got life without
parole just to make it clear in the u.s.
life means until you die mizanskey has
brought some of the records that
document has struggled with the sentence
I got this about six seven months ago
it's mostly going around on the internet
he talks about the internet but he's
never used it no access in prison my son
tried to tell me a little bit about it
how it works and this and that and it's
all French to me you know the sentence
seems French to him too
he was caught three times with marijuana
with significant amounts prosecution
said he was trying to deal is an ski
denies that but even if he was this
punishment seems unreasonably harsh I
was in different state I'd probably been
out a long time ago just about any other
state Missouri's got laws that they
follow certain ways and nonviolent crime
and then people that get convicted of
murder get out on a parole but there's
no possibility of parole for mizanskey
and his only chance is clemency from the
democratic Missouri governor jay Nixon
such a move would be very rare but the
former construction worker has not given
up hope just yet partly because of
what's going
in other states regarding the
legalization of cannabis that I got a
loving family that helps a lot
they got a lot of hope so besides that I
got the Lord he's the biggest that's it
but if earthly salvation really is on
the way will it arrive in time
Basanti is 61 years old that was an
angel but I don't believe I deserve this
even after 20 years behind bars he can
still imagine a life beyond this prison
one of the first things in my list is to
be weak to [ __ ] my mother's and
father's grave final gift closure
oh and that's it my time is up I'm
shakin because from today's perspective
it's hard for me to understand why Jeff
mizanskey has to stay in prison for the
rest of his life even if you'd been
caught with a full ton of marijuana it
just seems wrong there is one man who
might be able to help me understand
before I wrap up my trip I stopped by in
Sedalia one hour away from the prison
facility
Jeff middle Hauser still works in the
same building as back then he was the
prosecutor in mizanskey case and got
more than he bargained for he offered a
plea deal 20 years with parole but
mizanskey declined because it seemed so
much the judge in charge then struck
with the full force of the law mizanskey
was first a persistent drug offender
meaning he had at least two prior felony
convictions and then the next offense
the third offense couldn't be simply
possession and it couldn't be simply
possession of a small amount he had to
be found guilty of possession with
intent to deliver not surprisingly
middle Hauser is critical at the
cannabis legalization going on in other
states but nevertheless he has trouble
being at peace with the mizanskey case
two weeks ago I wrote a letter to
Missouri governor jay Nixon I explained
some of the background of the offense I
explained some mr. Masson skeez
background but I also recommended
clemency for him I told the governor
that I thought that the nearly 20 years
he served now is enough for what he did
things move at a slower pace in Missouri
than Colorado but even here cannabis
legislation seems in for a change when
people like Jeff middle Hauser stand up
for someone like MS Ann ski
on my way back I see one last reminder
of this highly symbolic case a giant
billboard sponsored by a pro-marijuana
organization mizanskey overlooking the
freeway prison or prosperity
depending on the state those are the
options for people who trade or deal
with marijuana even if things are
changing when it comes to cannabis the
u.s. is still schizophrenic